ونتابع هذه التغطيه باستطلاع الاوضاع
الانسانيه وهي من بين النقاط المهمه
والملفات الجد مهمه في هذه المرحله من
جناف المدير الاقليمي للجنه دوليه للصليب
الاحمر في افريقيا باتريك يوسف سيد بطريق
اهلا بك معنا مبدئيا كيف تتابعون الوضع
الانساني الحالي في السودان غوتيريش كان
وصفه في مقابله بالخطير وصفه منذ قليل
بالكارث كيف تتابعون التفاصيل
اولا شكرا
اكيد الوضع صعب جدا جدا واكيد ما فيهم من
المبالغه وقتها نقول انه الوضع ممكن يصير
كارثه اكثر واكثر اذا الوضع الانساني ما
استتب واذا
المجال للمنظمات الانسانيه خاصه العامله
بمجال الاغاثه الصحه المياه انه
تتدخل بطريقه سريعه جدا راح نشهد اكيد
انقطاع مش بس بمواد طبيه ولكن عدم تسيير
المرافق العامه راح يكون للاسف الشيء اللي
راح نواجهه
قريبا وهذا الشيء ما انه ابدا ايجابي
بالعكس لازم نتدخل بسرعه لما تتفاقم
الاوضاع اكثر واكثر
بان هناك مستشفيات علقت عملها لانقطاع
المياه لعدم قدرات الكوادر الطبيه للوصول
لها هل رصدتم او هل تاكدتم من هذا الموضوع
والله اكيد صعب كتير نتاكد من كل
المستشفيات المرافق العامه الكبيره اللي
عندها كميه وتستقبل اكيد بعدها عم تشتغل
بس مثل ما عم نقول الوقت مش لمصلحتها متل
ما بنعرف المشكله الاساسي اليوم اللي عم
نتعرض اللي عم تتعرض له العاصمه هو مع
استمرار الاشتباكات والاطلاق النار
والانفجارات عم تكون كلها على مقربه من
المناطق السكنيه المكتظه بالسكان وهذه
المرافق
الاماكن لازم تكون عندها حمايه خاصه
للمدنيين بطريقه تانيه ما بدنا نعرف انه
الاشخاص تعتمد وخاصه بالمدن الكبيره على
المرافق العامه لتوصل لتستلم خدماتها
الصحيه المياه الطاقه الى اخره وهذا الشيء
لازم نحميه كرماليك دعينا امبارح لضروره
احترام كافه الاطراف القانون دوله
الانساني والاعراف والقوانين السودانيه
حتى هيك لما تقول لازم نحميه بمعنى انه
متابعه فقط او انكم تتدخلون كذلك تطرحون
افكار لمحاوله فتح ممرات امنه لمحاوله
التهدئه على الاقل خدمه للمدنيين اكيد
ستنا هو التدخل مش بس باطلاق حملات
علنيه او اطلع بالاعلام الهدف هو انه نكمل
حوارنا
المباشر مع الاطراف النزاع مثل ما ذكرته
كمان ذكرت العربيه اكثر من شهر
ضروره تكثيف تدريب الكوادر العسكريه ان
كان الجيش ولا تدخل السريع على المفاهيم
القانون دوله الانساني واكيد بمتابعتنا
الحديثه على الارض مع الجهات المعنيه
العسكريه ونحاول انه نحمي هالمرافق بس
اكيد اللي حامل سلاح بده ياخذ امر لحتى لا
يؤذي المدنيين ولا يؤذي المرافق
قلت بانه منذ شهر تواصلتم مع الجانبين في
هذه الاسنان نزلتم تتواصلون معهم وفي اي
اطار والله التواصل ما توقف عم نحكي تاريخ
صليب الاحمر اكثر من 40 سنه بالسودان ولكن
الهدف منه اليوم هو ظل ظروف الراهنه انه
التدخل السريع
لاستجابه للاحتياجات الانسانيه هو يكون
الاساس وبتامل اكيد نحن مثل ما بتعرفي
ستنا ما قلنا دخل بالعمل السياسي ولكن بهل
ظرف الخاص اللي عم نقطع فيه ضروري التذكير
ومتابعه حمايه المرافق العامه والمدنيين
والاشخاص المصابين يعني يضرروا الحمايه
معينه تحت القانون دوله انساني هو
ولكن ودت الوقوف معك على مجريات العمل كيف
تعملهم بمعنى
لديكم فرق على الارض
تتواصلون مع
الطرفين وما الذي قيل لكم هل هناك وعود
مثلا بمحاوله فتح ممرات امنه بعد ما في
وعود ولكن تواصل مستكمل اكيد كان الصليب
الاحمر اللي عنده اكثر من 400 موظف بدرفور
بكثره بالنيل الازرق وبالخرطوم ام او
جمعيه الهلال الاحمر السوداني اللي عندها
اكبر عدد من
المتطوعين على الاراضي السودانيه او
المنظمتين والصليب الاحمر وهي الاحمر
بالاضافه الى الشهود الحديثه اللي عم تقوم
فيها منظمات ثانيه وعم نتواصل معها هدفها
انه نوصل على ارض الواقع للاسف بعد
النتيجه الايجابيه ما سمعناها طيب منذ
قليل كان هناك تصريح للسيد عبد الفتاح
البرهان الف فتح البرهان قال فيه بان
الجيش السوداني وافق على ثلاث ساعات تهدئه
لفتح ممرات امن الاكيد بانكم استمعتم لهذه
الاخبار والاكيد بانه هناك عمل قائم
لمحاوله ايصال المساعدات حدثني كيف هي
الصوره كيف تتابعون هذا العمل وكيف تعملون
من داخل السودان والله الهدف هو انه مثل
ما مثل ما ذكرتي انه هالوعود الترجمه على
ارض الواقع مش بس بفتره الافطار او ثلاثه
اربع ساعات نتامل انه يكون في اكثر من
اكثر فتره لحتى تدخل مواد طبيه على
الخرطوم مثل ما بنعرف اذا ما نفكر الحصار
على المطار ما بنقدر ندخل طيارات موجود
فيها او علامتنا مساعدات اضافيه طارئه
لازم تدخل على البلد هيدول هي الامور
الحديثه اللي بدنا نتبعها والجهود يلي
بعدوها المسؤولين انه تترجم على ارض
الواقع هذا الهدف افهم الكلام حضرتك بان
اساليب الاحمر تعطلوا وصولها للسودان في
هذه الاثناء واحد لليوم ما قدرنا نكثف
مساعدتنا ما بدنا ننسى انه الجمعه الماضيه
كنا بعدنا قادرين نتحرك وندخل ونطلع ولكن
جهودنا كانت مركزه على مناطق ثانيه دارفور
وين في نزاعات ابدا انه الخرطوم يصير فيها
اللي صار فيها بتامل انه الجهد يتكثف اكثر
واكثر خاصه اليوم انه الوضع ما بيحمل
ضروري انه نركز على الخرطوم ام درمان مروي
وغير مناطق عم يصير فيها نزاعات واشتباكات
عنيفه ولكن صليب الاحمر لم يدخل بمساعداته
للخرطوم منذ بدء الاشتباكات او دخلتم
وفيما بعد ان حصلت اشتباكات داخل ما دخلتم
من الخرطوم هل يمكن ان تصل موجود هذا واضح
ولكن بالنسبه
بصراحه من الخطا انه اليوم قول اي رقم ما
يكون رسمي طالع من جهه رسميه وما بدنا
نزيد ابدا مثل ما قلت المعلومات الخاطئه
نتامل انه بهالفتره الجايه نقدر الفرق
تقدر تنزل على ارض الواقع وتشوف وتتعامل
مع مكاتب الصحه مكاتب المياه يلي هي على
اساسها واكيد تواصل مع الجيش والفرق
العسكريه اللي هي اول واخيرا عندها بتكون
معلومات وهذا اللي بيقدر يعطينا لمحه عامه
عن الوضع اللي عم بيصير اللي همي انا
اقوله اليوم هو انه ما احترام القانون ومع
سماح لطواقم الطبيه والاسعافيه والمنظمات
الانسانيه والعمل انا متاكد انه الوطء
بتكون اقل ولكن بدها قرار سياسي جريء
ليوقف اطلاق النار ليسمح
للمنظمات الانسانيه بالتدخل السريع
ما المنظمات ما المؤسسات التي تتفاعلون
تتعاونون معها فداخل السودان يعني اسماء
مثلا مع من تتواصلون الله اكبر هي الهلال
الاحمر السوداني مع انها هو
الشريك الاول والاخير
الاساسي الموجود بالسودان وموجود بكافه
الاراضي اكيد في منظمات امميه مثل جمعيه
الصحه العالميه وغير مؤسسات عند عمل
مؤسسات سودانيه قبل ما تكون دوليه عم
تشتغل شغل ممتاز جدا ولازم دعمها واكيد
دعم فرقنا ودعم الهلال الاحمر هو ضروري
لانه اليوم مثل ما بنعرف الوضع الانساني
عامه حول العالم الاحتياجات عم تزيد ان
كان باثيوبيا ولا بالصومال ولا بغيرها ما
لازم ننسى اللي عم يصير بالسودان وما لازم
الاشتباكات بس تذكرنا بالاحتياجات
الانسانيه بالسودان السودان عم بيقطع
بمرحله صعبه وضروره اليوم ان نامن
للمساعده ما هي مخاوفكم سيد باتريك يعني
انهي معك بهذه النقطه منذ البدايه قلت بان
الوضع خطير وقادر ان يكون كارثه تتخوفون
من ماذا مع استمرار الاشتباكات والله متل
ما عم بحكي عم نسمع بالتقرير عندك
انفجارات كل حياه شخص سمينه جدا كل حياه
طفل مراه او رجال سمينه جدا كل حياه
سوداني مهمه جدا لالنا كرمالك لازم ننتبه
انه ما حدا عم يقول نحن اليوم ما قلنا
دعوه
بالنتيجه اللي عم بيحصل سياسيا وعسكريا بس
منقوله هو انه ننتبه لحمايه المدنيين
ونامن الخدمات الاساسيه ما عم نطلب اكثر
من هيك للشعب السوداني اللي عم بيعيش كمان
متل ما قلنا فتره رمضانيه حرجه جدا
بتاملها بوصول العيد قريبا انه تنتج لشيء
ايجابي او تشكرك جزيلا شكر على تلبيه
الدعوه وكل ما تفضلت به من معلومات من
جنيف المدير الاقليمي للجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر في افريقيا باتريك يوسف
شكرا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات